we really wanted to walk every character
through their entire arc in the MCU and
think about what was the most satisfying
conclusion frigid because that was our
job on this movie caps a guy who's
already tried to sacrifice his life we
know that about cap that he can sacrum
so we thought the most satisfying ending
for him would be to finally get his
greatest loss back to retrieve his
greatest loss and that sort of missed
opportunity with Peggy you know Tony
Stark is a very opposite arc that we
were following with him where this guy
started from a very self-centered
arrogant place and so the greatest
ending for his narrative would be to
reach a moment of selflessness sacrifice
so he and that's what he does there and
he had a lot to lose in that moment but
he Tony Stark was always fated to die
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
the ending to Avengers endgame when Tony
Stark says I am Iron Man and snaps his
fingers is quite possibly the saddest
moment in the MCU however it could also
possibly be one of the most fulfilling
scenes in the entirety of the MCU Iron
Man saved the universe and we wouldn't
have it any other way and according to
the Russo brothers it couldn't be any
other way
previously the Russo brothers have
spoken about how narrative Lee it made
sense Iron Man was the closest to Thanos
that could get the Infinity Gauntlet so
therefore he snapped but now they have
recently opened up in an interview as
far as characters are concerned it could
have only been Iron Man to perform the
snap and make that sacrifice
I'll show footage of the interview and
break it all down but first be sure to
hit the subscribe button right now I'm
doing a giveaway picking 3 winners at
the 400,000 subscriber mark to choose
one item from the Marvel Legends series
collection Tony Stark was always fated
to die he's a futurist and he always saw
on the horizon the danger that was
coming and that's why he tried to create
a suit of armor around the world in
Ultron he always said it's coming from
up there he could feel it and he would
never rest and pepper says this to him
in the movie you know would you be able
to rest when he talks about you know
taking this discovery of time-travel I'm
throwing it up putting in a box and
throwing at the bottom of the lake and
she says yeah but could you could you
rest and he can't he can't rest until
the job is done and and if it requires
sacrificing his life to do it and I
think people ascribe you know
a bad energy towards dying yeah it's not
it's not great to die however but when
you do it under heroic circumstances and
you do it to preserve the universe
there's something inspiring and
ennobling and and hopeful about that
so as the Russo brothers say he was
always fated to die he always felt this
threat coming and he would never be able
to rest until he eliminated this threat
this is something that we've heard him
say has been eating away his mind since
the very first Avengers film when he
went inside the wormhole ever since that
moment the greater threat that is Thanos
has been haunting him and we saw it
haunt him throughout all of the films in
the MCU that he was in an Iron Man 3 he
literally couldn't rest and then in age
of Ultron this is why he built Ultron to
stop these great threats that are coming
from outer space and like Joe Russo said
that is why he wanted the suit of armor
around the world and this is something
that Tony even says to Steve in Avengers
endgame so this is something that Tony
has taken responsibility for in his mind
it was his job to save the universe no
matter what the cost even if that was
sacrificing himself even when he had a
wife and a daughter
it was Tony Stark's personal mission to
save the world and the universe which is
why it had to be Tony Stark to perform
that final snap and Avengers end game so
that's why it had to be Tony Stark to
perform that final snap according to the
Russo brothers and Avengers in game let
me know what you think about what the
Russo brothers had to say in that
interview and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
the giveaway and of course they up to
date on everything relating to Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]